okay let's go next game
thank you jib pibley
aki 90.
okay playing god dave ooh let's play a
stafford maybe
well hello eric i was able to catch your
stream for two months due to covid oh
sorry to you back oh
now
yeah chess is a continual journey
of hardness but it can be rewarding if
you stick with it
be persistent
throw in some staffords
good to have you back hacky 90.
okay so this is um this is a line where
white's playing safe
um
and i'm i'm being very direct
going for this typical
knight g4 idea
and yeah this line it's subjectively
dubious but it's very hard to figure out
how to refute like over the board eric
your video with hess was amazing such
great content as always
yeah it was a fun sub battle robert is a
like
super good commentator so it's cool to
do some commentary with him
especially on uh lower level games
so this is a move
wait did i already
i already go wrong
because d4 is coming
remember this wasn't so supposed to be
good but i forgot why
queen g3 d4
i gotta move quicker too okay let's play
bishop here
yeah this will be a lesson to look at
after the game
so i'm keeping the the tension
uh
i guess i'll castle
a4a5
as risky play but this is uh
what i get for playing a stafford maybe
a6 actually
because if a5 there is b4
some cool g5 move maybe
bishop g5 rook here
that's probably what the position calls
for
thank you billy
i love you too
so after this game i'll share my secret
stafford prep file
uh in jazz base
i have a pretty extensive file on
the variation we went into
okay so g5 27
my thing is still hanging
yeah white
takes it which
i guess is logical
stick with bishop
actually
let's try this
idea to triple up and then mate
and lights kind of trapped now
oh but the knights returning to g4
i'm getting outplayed
yeah i like playing this well
there's still hope maybe
let's play
this move first
good move
thanks for all the great content happy
hump day all oh happy hunter
i'm getting forked
[Music]
pawns go falling
bye
i feel kind of bad
i also feel kind of good
my hand sanitizer
i have um
i have disinfectant wipes